of course nothing can top the amount of
underwater filming Radcliffe did for the
famous Wizarding tournament in Goblet of
Fire one of the challenges involved him
and the other competing Wizards trying
to rescue their friends from underwater
traps that meant hours and hours of
getting footage of them underwater
Daniel wasn't already scuba certified so
first he had to endure 6 months of
training before they started filming
then came the hard part they filmed a
total of 41 hours of footage of him
underwater and unless you happen to have
G that's a lot of time underwater he
ended up with serious ear infections on
two different occasions and according to
Daniel they only used about 7 Seconds a
day of the footage they got but
ultimately he felt it was the right
decision he said quote there was a lot
of talk of someone else doing it and
superimposing my face on it that would
have looked like rubbish